[Music]
on the 4th of June we arrived at
Constantinople and after a miserable
reception meant as an insult to
yourselves we were given the most
miserable and disgusting quarters the
palace where we were confined was
certainly large and opened but it
neither kept out the cold nor afforded
shelter from the heat armed soldiers
were said to guard us and prevent my
people from going out and any others
from coming in this dwelling only
accessible to us who were shot inside it
was so far distant from the Emperor's
residence that we were quite out of
breath when we walked there we did not
ride to add to our troubles the Greek
wine we found undrinkable and because of
the mixture in it of pitch resin and
plaster the house itself had no water
and we could not even buy a knee to
quench our thirst all this was a was a
serious Oh dear me
but there was another Oh dear me even
worse and that was our warden the man
who provided us with our daily wants if
you were to seek another like him you
certainly would not find him on earth
you might perhaps inhale on the 6th of
June which was the Saturday before
Pentecost I was brought before the
Emperor's brother Leo marshal of the
court enchanter and there we tired
ourselves with a fierce argument over
your Imperial title he called you not
Emperor which is Basilius in his tongue
but
insultingly Rex which is king in ours I
told him the thing meant was the same
though the word was different and he
then said that I had come not to make
peace but to stir up strife finally he
got up in a rage and really wishing to
insult us received your letter not in
his own hand but through an interpreter
he's a man commanding enough in person
but
feigning humility where on if a man
alene it'll pierce his hand on the
seventh of June a sacred day of
Pentecost I was bought before and I care
for us himself in the palace called
stefana that is the crown palace he is a
monstrosity of a man a wharf fat-headed
and with tiny moles eyes disfigured by a
short broad thick beard half going gray
disgraced by a neck
scarcely an inch long pig-like by reason
of the big clothes bristles on his head
in color and Ethiopian and as the poet
says you would not like to meet him in
the dark a big belly lean posterior very
long in the hip considering his shorter
stature
small legs fair sized heels and feet
dressed in a robe made of fine linen but
old foul-smelling and discolored by age
shod with [ __ ] onin slippers bold of
tonga Fox by nature in perjury and
falsehood Ulysses my Lords and August
Emperor's you always seemed calmly to me
but ho how much more calmly now always
magnificent how much more magnificent
now always mighty how much more mighty
now always Clement how much more Clement
now always for the virtues how much
fuller now
and his left on on the line with him but
much lower down set the two child
Emperor's once his masters now his
subjects he began his speech as follows
[Music]
it was our duty and desire to give you a
courteous and magnificent reception that
however has been rendered impossible by
the impiety of your master who in the
guise of a hostile invader has laid
claim to Rome has robbed Berengar and
Adelbert of their kingdom contrary to
law and right has slain some of the
Romans by the sword some by hanging
while others he is either blinded or
sent into exile and furthermore has
tried to subdue himself by massacre and
conflagration cities belonging to our
Empire his wicked attempts have proved
unsuccessful and so he has sent you the
instigator and further of this villainy
under pretence of peace to act calm May
own Espeon that is as a spy among us
to him I made this reply my master did
not invade the city of Rome by force nor
as a tyrant he freed her from a tyrants
yoke or rather from the yoke of many
tyrants was she not ruled by effeminate
debauches and what is even worse and
more shameful by harlots your power
methinks was fast asleep then and the
power of your predecessors who in name
alone are called Emperor's of the Romans
while the reality is far different if
they were powerful if they were emperors
of the Romans why did they allow Rome to
be in the hands of harlots
well not some of the holy popes banished
others so distressed that they could not
procure their daily supplies nor money
wherewith to give arms did not Adelbert
to send insulting letters to your
predecessors the Emperor's Romanus and
Constantine did he not rob and plunder
the churches of the Holy Apostles who
view Emperor's led by seal for God
troubled to punish so heinous a crime
and bring back the Holy Church to its
proper state you neglected it my master
did not from the ends of the world he
rose and came to Rome and drove out the
ungodly and gave back to the vicars of
the holy apostles all their power and
honour those who afterwards rose against
him and the Lord Pope as being violators
of their oath sacrilegious robbers and
torturers of their Lords the Pope's in
accordance with the decrees of such
Roman emperors Justinian Valentinian
Theodosius etc he slowed the headed hand
or exiled if he had not done so he
himself would be an impious unjust cruel
tyrant it is a known fact that Berengar
and Adelbert became his vassals and
received the Kingdom of Italy with a
golden scepter from his hand and that
they promised fealty under oath in the
presence of your servants
men still alive and now dwelling in this
city at the devil's prompting they
perfidiously broke their word and
therefore he justly took their kingdom
from them as being deserters and rebels
you yourself would have done the same to
man who had sworn fealty and then
revolted against you but he said there
is one of Adelbert vassals here and he
does not acknowledge the truth of this
if he denies it I replied one of my men
at your command will prove to him
tomorrow in single combat that it is so
well say he he may as you declare have
acted justly in this explain now why he
attacked the borders of our empire with
war and conflagration we were friends
and were thinking by marriage to enter
into a partnership that would never be
broken this land I answered which you
say belongs to your empire is proved by
race and language to be part of the
Kingdom of Italy the Lombards held it in
their power and Lewie emperor of the
lombards or franks freed it from the
grip of the Saracens with great
slaughter for seven years also LAN Dolph
Prince of Benevento and Capua held it
under his control no one had even now
have passed from the yoke of slavery to
him and his descendants had not your
Emperor Romanus brought at a great price
the friendship of our King Hugh it was
for this reason also that he made a
match between King use bastard daughter
and his own nephew and namesake
I see now then you think it shows
weakness in my master not generosity
when after winning Italy and Rome he for
so many years left them to you the
friendly partnership which you say you
wished to form by a marriage we hold to
be a fraud and a snare you ask for a
truce
but you have no real reason to want it
in a way to grant it
let us clear away all trickeries and
speak the plain truth my master has sent
me to you to see if you will give the
daughter of the Emperor Romano's and the
Empress Thea far no to his son my master
the august emperor otto if you give me
your oath that the marriage shall take
place i am to affirm to you under oath
that my master in grateful return will
observe to do this and this for you
moreover he has already given you his
brother ruler the best pledge of
friendship by handing over Apulia which
was subject to his rule I do suggestion
you declare this mischief was due
intervened in this matter and there are
as many witnesses to this as there are
people in Apulia hmm it is past seven
o'clock
Sedna Karis and there is a church
procession which I must attend let us
keep the business between us we will
give you a reply at some convenient
season
[Music]
you